Ronda Rousey was was was knocked out
recently people thought that she was
could not be defeated you had been
through the same experience before where
people were psyched no one's ever gonna
beat Mike Tyson and then you lose to
Buster Douglas do you have advice for
her cuz she you know she's not out there
a lot she's not communicating a lot
she's been through a huge upset what did
you tell her she has to understand
wedding the hurt business and no and I
don't care if you're the king of the
herb business we're in the business
where we get hurt and she has got to be
think come off the house whatever she I
think she's been around show your faith
you're human yes um she says unfortunate
that she took Elias yeah you know um
David's a great king he's done great
that he built a civilization the King
David he built a civilization but he's
look but he's more famous for beating
Goliath right you know so he can never
see he's never like alive shadow like
young lady I miss home she's never gonna
be out around the shadow yeah that gave
her her life stickers a meal ticket and
that's a wonderful thing and from that
you saw in the late didn't lay that beat
Rhonda for a moment when I looked in her
corner and I saw I think was her brother
grabs man kissed him and I know that was
the happiness I used to feel when I was
fighting and I never had that happiness
kid I said wow that's it right there was
trying to tell us with my wife we
shouldn't get fifi that happy that's
what you do it rappers like get back on
the hoverboard
[Laughter]
[Applause]